if you want to see the epitome of
management by optics a term that we've
been discussing more and more lately I
have it for you today look no further
then CEOs told to remove their masks
before Mike Pence comes out to meet with
them imagine that people around Mike
Pence have tested positive three people
that we know of connected to the White
House have the virus more are in
quarantine
Pence's press secretary has the virus
Katie Miller she happens to be the wife
of Trump adviser Stephen Miller pens
should be in quarantine but is simply
not doing it he has a meeting over the
weekend with food industry CEOs they
show up wearing masks all five of them
they're doing the right thing
someone from Pence's staff comes out or
someone guided by Penza staff comes out
and tells them take off your masks
before the vice president comes out here
we actually have video of this you don't
even have to wonder how it went down
we're playing the video for our TV
audience you actually see someone come
out all of the CEOs are wearing masks
she goes up to the CEOs you see her say
something and she actually mimics the
motion of mask removal and they all do
it by the way notice how she's not
wearing a mask she gets right up in the
faces of these five CEOs this is
actually close enough to spread the
virus there is no explanation for this
other than image and optics this was
hours after Pence's own press secretary
tested positive for coronavirus and the
Trump administration has turned the mask
into a political element rather than
excuse my my phrase here it's a
political element rather than an element
of medical for lack of a better term now
I okay that's sort of a joke but this is
merely a public health item and it is
now being used politically if people all
around tents are wearing masks and Mike
Pence is not it could make Mike Pence
look bad but it also makes it seem like
it's unsafe out there and people have to
be worried about getting the virus which
they do
and that is why people are not allowed
to be masked up around Mike Pence during
this roundtable and it's all about
pretending everything's normal
it's about being economic warriors for
the stock market
Trump is increasingly using that term
economic warriors before people were
warriors for staying home now they're
warriors for not staying home it's
completely Orwellian Kayle mcenany was
asked about it at a recent press
briefing and reporters were confused
because at first it was I thought I
thought people were staying home and
that was that was the war we were
fighting but now it's people are
warriors by no longer staying home and
just getting out there and Kaylee Mackin
and he said that's right they're all
warriors when they were staying home
they were warriors now being out there
warriors and as usual these things
become vicious circles and
self-fulfilling prophecies because the
CDC recommended first responders wear
masks starting in very early April now
they didn't have them available police
departments fire departments etc needed
to find the masks but that was the
recommendation starting on April 3rd
that was five weeks ago imagine how much
better off we would be and how much
better off the economy would be this is
a point I keep making if on April 3rd
everybody started wearing masks if on
March 5th or seventh or tenth Donald
Trump said hey fifty governor's let's do
stay at home thirty days you probably
end up having to extend it fifteen or
thirty more that would be over by now we
would be done with that Trump just
pretending that everything is fine it
also won't work for the country tons of
people are going to die but this
make-believe play pretend stuff that the
Trump administration is doing about
business as usual it can work for a few
weeks but if the numbers don't improve
it's going to implode we have five and a
half months left before we will get the
opportunity to remove every last one of
these people and we have to not allow a
lot of the stuff we've talked about
today all needs to happen we can't allow
this stuff to become normal we can't
become numb to it the hyper
normalization happens naturally to some
degree humans just adapt to what's going
on if you're used to seeing 1,500 to
2,500 people a day die of coronavirus if
it happens for long enough
and most people's lives remember we're a
country of 331 million most people's
lives seems sort of stable it's very
easy for that to become normal
much the same way the continued
insistence or sort of make-believe is
essentially what it is about
everything's fine the economy is opening
here's a list of states opening testing
is great it's all great that does work
and we need to fight really hard to make
sure that we don't fall for it
one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a life saver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cashback and
lets you create thirty six credit cards
a month and a twenty five dollar a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create sixty card numbers
a month and much more but definitely go
ahead and Italy
get started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm slash
Pakman